foreign
other aircraft and its multi-domain
space cyber uh ground sea everything
working together against an enemy that
is also multi-domain as well so I would
say if you really had to boil it down 10
is dog fighting and how good your hands
are the rest of it is being able to
coordinate these large forces of
exercises and typically it's the fighter
pilots that are planning these exercises
and if you boil down my job as a fire
pot it's to make decisions and I think
it's more important than ever now any
sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic
[Music]
welcome to all three of you joining out
there uh wherever you may be or you're
joined today by two special guests
and uh myself Brian Keating uh your host
your fearful host of the into the
impossible podcast discussing the
impossibly delightful delicious
enjoyable book by today's guest Hazard
Lee which is called the art of clear
thinking and I'm joined today by a very
special guest live in the into the
impossible Studios making his first ever
podcast appearance and this is all right
my good friendly tenant Commander
Arielle kleinerman
graduate of many many disciplines and
places but including and not limited to
past guests on the show David spurgles
Princeton University Ariel welcome to
the podcast thanks pleasure to be on
thanks and it's a very auspicious day to
have a hazard on the podcast for many
reasons one it's uh when this comes out
uh not the live version which is coming
out today it will be the uh release date
of his first book The Art of clear
thinking and hopefully there'll be many
many more books to come it's been
endorsed by many many people that are
just incredible but I want to point out
past guest astronaut and Dr Scott
parazinski he's an incredible human
being my mom you know fell in love with
him when he was on the show I'm sure
she'll fall in love with Hazard as well
Hazard welcome to the show major Hazard
Lee how are you
Brian thanks for having me this is great
it's great to have a student I love this
book uh this has been such a treat to
read it and to really plow into it both
as a Private Pilot here in Southern
California
a big fan of the Air Force or my
stepfather was a Academy grad back in
the 60s flew tankers and Phantoms in
Vietnam and there's a lot of that in
this book as well as Lessons Learned for
individuals of all kinds but you know
I'm a scientist and your father being a
physicist you know all about that and
the science in this book is what really
stood out to me and made it so
delightful and such a such a quick and
and easy read but the storytelling is
what really stands out in this
magnificent book so the first question I
have you know we have a segment on the
show whenever an author honors me by
coming on I always ask them to judge the
book by its cover something you're never
supposed to do right Ariel you're never
supposed to judge a book by its couple
what else do you have to go on if you've
never written a book before is this your
first book so we do a judging books by
its cover where we ask you to go through
the title The subtitle and the cover art
if any and the most important thing I
want to ask you why did you choose the
art of clear thinking not the science
sense of clear thinking so take it away
help us judge this book by its wonderful
cover
[Music]
yeah I love that because that's the
first thing you see when you go into a
bookstore so
um yeah I I really wanted to show that
uh there's a lot of books on decision
making out there but this is one through
a little bit different of a lens
somebody who is you know in the hot seat
making these decisions so
for me it's a little bit more of an art
than a science although I talk through
both so there are opinion based
decisions there are database decisions
but for me when you're actually in the
moment when you don't have time to fully
analyze and process every single
variable in detail a lot of it comes
down to the art of making a good
decision and I think a lot of people
struggle making decisions I did Growing
Up it wasn't until I became a fighter
pilot and really found a good framework
for making decisions and I think as you
know Ariel was saying you know I'm
interested to hear your take when you
fly especially when you solo as soon as
you take off you know that you're the
only one your decision making is the
only thing that can get you back to the
ground so for me as soon as I soloed
um it really changed the way that I see
the world so
um so that's that's something that is
important and I wanted to to convey that
with the cover with the F-35 I am an
F-35 pilot
um so that's that's where the plane came
from and then a stealth fighter Pilot's
Timeless rules for making tough
decisions so I wanted to Showcase uh a
little bit of my bio in the subtitle so
some of it was technical some of it was
you know as as I talked to opinion based
decisions but I think it you know I mean
I'll leave it up to you but um you know
I'm pretty excited for uh for what me
and the team at St Martin's press came
up with yeah it's it's really a
tremendous accomplishment uh the reason
I didn't mention but the reason Arielle
is joining us today is he is a retired
lieutenant commander in the Navy where
he flew uh the Super Hornet so there we
have you know actually two real-life
American Heroes on the podcast today and
I brought this bag here which I got from
an author by the name of Russell Monroe
for his recent book he makes this
cartoon called XKCD and it's it for use
in case of motion discomfort and I
solicited questions from my audience but
the first thing I want to do is point
out today Hazard you may know or not
know is the 33rd anniversary 3 of the
release of Top Gun today May 16th so
it's an auspicious day to have a Navy
fighter pilot on as well so I want to
turn the first question over to my
friend Ariel and I think we had kind of
a similar uh discussion over over lunch
at least at one point I I remember
hearing from my neighbors here in San
Diego John and Martha King that the day
you become a pilot your identity has
changed forever so I want to ask uh as a
fighter pilot as a fellow fighter pilot
what came away from reading this book
what kind of commonalities do you
perceive between maybe Air Force stealth
fighter pilots and following the super
Hornets that you engage with what kinds
of similarities are there and are there
any important differences that a
layperson like me effectively would not
take away from this from this wonderful
new book
no one of the things I enjoyed is I
created mental bottles for myself as I
went through training things that I
thought made me successful and and how I
approach problem sets
um and then I found that Hazard did a
very succinct job of putting that down
and writing much better than I've ever
done but you know these are models that
I developed through flying and then also
instructing I also that was another part
of the book that I really liked was the
distress on on instructing and how to be
a an effective instructor I found I
didn't get a solid
uh background into how to be a proper
instructor and I approached it with the
wrong mindset at first
um and over time through trial and error
kind of came to a similar area that
Hazard did as well of you know trying to
reinforce the student build them up
approach them from a different aspect as
opposed to what we do pretty frequently
in the fighter Community which is
evaluation it's every every flight is
essentially a test
um but no I found the book to be uh you
know the quick mental math problems I I
had a fun uh it reminded me I would
often my students would be there with a
whiz wheel which is essentially an
analog computer for calculating
distance time Fuel and I would uh do fun
games with them of like hey I'm gonna do
this in my head you do it on the whiz
wheel we'll see who does better and
inevitably using very similar techniques
to what hazard puts in the book I would
come up with with a better answer than
they would get two minutes later on The
Wiz wheel with their heads down low
situation awareness uh so Hazard one of
the things that I I took away is uh
there are these different you know kind
of Ways Mental models shortcuts Etc but
one thing I always remember hearing from
I think it was from a fellow F-18 pilot
of Ariel's which was you know if you're
relying on hand-eye coordinate you know
people say oh Hazard you must have like
this phenomenal hand-eye coordination
you could just make Split Second
reactions the book I came away with a
very different perspective and I wonder
how much do you rely on that um you know
on kind of the the base Primal limbic
system versus deep ingrained systems
training thought processes acronyms Etc
how much is physical mental and if you
could give us a breakdown like I'm I
came away very interested in your
training routine both for both you guys
are an exceptional shade right the shape
that I can only aspire I I'm lucky
Hazard because unlike you I can I'm
always pulling like two G's I'm you know
I've got I've got enough math on me that
I'm always pulling two G's but anyway uh
tell me please what is the physical and
mental relationship how much is hand-eye
how much is intrinsic innate and um and
how much do you have to rely on actual
cognitive processes versus physical
looks yeah that's a great question so a
lot of people think that when we take
off and and fight thanks to to movies
like Top Gun which is a phenomenal movie
but that it's this 1v1 cage match we're
going up we're pairing our best pilot
and our best jet going against you know
Russia China's best pilot and their best
jet
um but it's really it really is that
system's thinking you're going out with
potentially a hundred other aircraft and
its multi-domain space cyber uh ground
sea everything working together against
an enemy that is also multi-domain as
well so I would say if you really had to
boil it down 10 is dog fighting and how
good your hands are the rest of it is
being able to coordinate these large
forces of exercises and typically it's
the fighter pilots that are planning
these exercises as well so we'll plan
them several days sometimes several
years out with you know dozens sometimes
hundreds of people all trying to align
towards this common goal of overall
mission success so it's a lot less than
it used to be if you go back to World
War II we have a lot of systems and
sensors in place you're using that 35
it's a flying sister system it's a
flying computer it's phenomenal how well
it can do that and if you're busy just
yanking and banking the whole time
you're losing that cognitive processing
ability to be able to maintain
situational awareness so about 10 hands
you still have to have good hands we're
still training to dogfight it's
something that is is very possible but
it's a lot less important than it used
to be you talked before we started
recording and then Arielle will have a
question about your Ace framework versus
the ooda loop framework but you talked
uh we were chatting and I watched on
your Instagram feed by the way everyone
has to follow his YouTube channel his
podcast and his Instagram is just you
know it's just like you live vicariously
through Hazard uh it's just so
delightful uh but one of them is a video
with uh one of my heroes Tito Ortiz
who's uh you have cmma just an
incredible guys huge he's he's probably
my weight but you know one percent body
fat gets in the uh the commercial I
guess a civilian G machine
um I forget the name of it hazardous in
a second and he he you know g-locks at
or we should explain what that is but he
passes out at like nine G's and I'm like
you know Hazard you're like yeah that's
just you know breakfast for me but but
talk about just the physical you know uh
training what what is like a routine
you're going flying uh you know in the
morning and a lot of my listeners are
astronomers and we want to thank oh we
gotta really be ready it's life or death
we hit the telescope but sometimes we
have to sleep you know if I'm using a
telescope like the telescope it's ten
thousand dollars an hour
um you know if I'm not a cognitive Peak
it's gonna be a tremendous cost to my
grants or to my uh funding agency how do
you deal with the physical demands of
your of your highly intellectual Pursuit
you know the brain uses most of the
calories in the body and when it's at
rest but you have a physical training
routine and you have any tools tips
techniques to get sleep when it counts
that's really important and then Arielle
I want you to ask about your they would
have lived per seism yeah absolutely so
flying a fighter a lot of people are
like you're just in a seat how difficult
could it be but we are pulling upwards
of nine G's nine times the force of
gravity so right now I'm at 1G I weigh
about uh 200 pounds 230 with my gear on
at 9 G's that's over 2 000 pounds of
force just crushing you into your seat
and you know as you saw Tito Ortiz one
of the most fit people on the planet
ninth person ever to be inducted into
the UFC Hall of Fame he wanted to come
out and see what fighter pilot training
was like so we put him into the nastar
centrifuge and uh this is all credit to
him he he wanted to do the full fighter
pilot profile he didn't want the old man
you know kind of tour of it that only
goes up to Four G's so nine G's nine
times the force of gravity he ended up
g-locking so that's a g induced loss of
consciousness
um so with the the forces that were
pulling it's uh vertical so it's pulling
the blood out of your brain and putting
it into your extremities and it's doing
it with enough force that it can rupture
your blood vessels so after a flight
it'll look like I have chickenpox on my
arms and my legs and that's from those
that pressure of the blood eruption
those blood vessels but the real threat
is passing out if you lose enough blood
you'll pass out and if the speeds we're
flying typically we're going to be
oriented with our nose down in full
afterburner so that's 40 plus thousand
pounds of thrust pointed you know pretty
much straight down and it you'll be
incapacitated for about 30 seconds and
it speeds were flying it takes about 20
seconds to impact the ground so
unfortunately we've lost about One Pilot
a year to a GM Deuce loss of
consciousness where they pass out and
they impact the ground going you know
800 miles an hour so it's something that
we really focus on and it comes down to
physical training comes down to
nutrition so just being just being three
percent dehydrated can reduce your G
tolerance Time by 50 so you have to stay
hydrated you have to eat well you have
to work out with your legs a lot uh how
we're flying it's typically pulling a
lot of cheese resting for a little bit
pulling a lot of is resting for a little
bit so it looks a lot like hit training
so we'll do a lot with that and this is
probably the biggest thing that's
changed in the air force over the last
10 years when I first joined it was it
was a little bit like golf might have
been in the 90s you had a lot of John
Daly types people that were really
talented good Pilots but they didn't
treat human performance seriously and uh
I remember some of the instructors early
on saying you know you didn't really
have to train for G's just go out and
smoke a cigarette before your flight
because that would reduce your shrink
your arteries to increase your blood
pressure so you know over the last 10
years we've really focused on human
performance because of all those people
dying and so we now have nutritionists
that work with us we have physical
therapists because you do have a lot of
back and neck issues a lot of people
have to retire early
you have to sleep is a huge Factor as
you mentioned so probably the average
fighter pilot could pull 10 10 and a
half maybe 11 G's but each one of those
things if you're dehydrated if you have
a lot of stress if you didn't sleep well
it lowers the bar for you and it just
takes one time of going over your limit
that uh that can unfortunately in you so
sleeping is a big thing you know we'll
sometimes have briefings at five in the
morning when I was flying in Afghanistan
I would fly the graveyard shift so I
would go in and I would fly from 11 P.M
to to 5 p.m we do have some uh drugs
that were prescribed for extreme things
like that Dexter amphetamine but you
know it's not the best thing to uh to
take continually so for me getting a
good night's sleep comes down it's
probably what most people have heard
getting off your devices having a
routine uh exercising during the day and
then having a sound machine is important
especially if you're on that graveyard
shift everything seems to conspire
against you it's probably something that
you experience uh being in a telescope
and I'm sure they want to maximize the
amount of time they can use that so when
you're using you know when you're
working in the middle of the night
everything especially if you have kids
conspires against you to uh to try and
wake you up in the morning so having
blackout curtains keeping the keeping
the room cool so all the standard stuff
that that people have heard but I think
it's just staying disciplined and making
sure that you're checking all those
boxes well you gotta um you know kind of
take up the the mantle of my friend and
local uh celebrity Jocko willink here
you got to start making supplements
Hazard I see that in your future
um all right you and I were talking
about UDA you were trying to explain
what UDA is besides you know it sounds
like a character in uh like an Oompa
Loompa but what is this and and the and
the ace framework that Hazard can you
compare and contrast those and how could
we apply those those of us that are you
know just flying Microsoft flight
simulator
yeah so the ooda loop was uh developed
by John Boyd one of uh our most famous
fighter pilots I believe he also helped
uh lead the team designing the F-16 and
I'm sure Hazard could correct me being
an F-16 pilot here uh but ooda Loop is a
observed Orient decide and act
um and then Hazard your Ace framework is
the assess choose and execute correct
correct wondering if you could kind of
walk us through how you you know what
are what are the differences what are
the improvements on the ooda loop model
with the ace framework
I don't want to say there are any
improvements the one thing about Air
Force pilot training is that we're not
really taught on what John Boyd the
history of John Boyd I have his book
over my shoulder he's uh you know one of
the forefathers of decision making
Theory so he's done a phenomenal job but
I think the Air Force is unique in that
it doesn't really adhere to Dogma so we
take whatever we can and are always
moving forward and so Boyd had a huge
impact in it but he really isn't taught
per se and unfortunately he didn't write
a book
um but anybody that goes to to Air Force
pilot training and uh goes through uh
fighter training is taught a framework
similar to uh the ace uh Helix so assess
choose and execute so in order to be
able to consistently make good decisions
you have to first be able to have a high
fidelity understanding of that problem
so as Pilots we call that the cross
check being able to see which variables
are important discard the other ones so
I talk in the book about uh finding the
the non-linear ones that are uh have an
exponential return for instance ejecting
lots of things to do most important
thing just slow down because it does not
increase uh linearly but it increases
Force increases exponentially with speed
so being able to assess then choose so
part of choosing is being able to
develop a lot of courses of action so
that's where I have a chapter about
creativity and developing those courses
of action a lot of people choose to skip
this step and just they want to
and you know there's a lot of reasons
for that one of the big ones is that
it's tough to measure progress when
you're brainstorming so people just want
to pick something and start moving on
and then lastly being able to execute on
that decision so there is a lot of
psychology here when we're flying in
missions in Afghanistan there might have
been a thousand people that touched that
mission from spies on the ground to
satellite operators to people uh in the
chaos to tankers launching from other
continents all to Get You On Target on
time and so there's that's a lot of
pressure a lot of eyeballs on you it's
not like the old days where nobody can
monitor you so everybody's monitoring
what you're doing and so there's a lot
of pressure and being an instructor I've
seen a lot of students choke and so it's
about being able to control your
emotions and being able to execute while
Under Pressure so that's the the
framework uh that we use as fighter
pilots
both of you guys are instructors and you
know let's kind of self identification
for for me personally as an instructor
in addition to being a a father and
hopefully a decent uh a decent husband
but um instruction comes up a lot in
this book and when I think about
instruction I think at least in my
profession Hazard of being a professor
things haven't changed in over a
thousand years you know back in the year
1080 in Bologna Italy the first major
university in the west that's still in
existence today the uh there was a guy
and he would stand up with a piece of
rock and scrape on the on the wall up
here and you know and he'd scrape in
front of on another giant piece of rock
or slab of stone and you know how much
is how little has changed in you know a
thousand years and we don't even have
things like simulators and and things
that have really Advanced knowledge but
I wonder when I think about education
I've spoken to some of the greatest
Educators in the world including Carl
Wyman winner of the Nobel Prize who's
started his career after winning the
Nobel Prize to teaching how to teach and
he called education modern day
professori at class kind of the
equivalent of medicine and the era of
bloodletting and leeches and I wonder
you know where do you see the future of
Education inside the cockpit we were
talking before the the show aired that
um you know that when you put on the
helmet you guys you know claim that you
lose 20 IQ points I say you know that
leaves me percent brain power fifty
percent okay so that that then leaves me
at negative capacity I find the same
thing in front of a chalkboard you know
I'm sitting up there stuff I could do
you know sitting in my sleep probably
and I'm in front of a class of students
and trying to scrape some stuff on a
chalkboard but um but it's it comes down
to you know kind of different uh
platforms of Education that roughly
align with Maslow's hierarchy of needs
at some level but I wonder what you guys
think about the following proposal if
it's so effective to teach according to
Maslow's needs you know have physical
safety to have you know emotional safety
and support what if you could kind of
you know do the opposite and see the you
know so I've often thought in the
simulator we should have like an M80 go
off like when you crash the simulator
Like I Do It For Fun you know I'm Gonna
Fly underneath the Golden Gate Bridge in
my F-18 and Microsoft flights but if I
really you know if there all of a sudden
was a joy buzzer that went off on my
butt you know maybe I'd have more
visceral reaction Hazard what do you
think the future of Education inside the
cockpit and outside the cockpit what do
you what would you propose to bring it
more into the modern era well that that
is a great question and that's what I
worked on on my last assignment in
active duty so
pilot training had not changed that much
in 60 years and with the F-35 it was a
big opportunity we had multiple
communities coming together A10 F22 F-15
Luke Air Force Base is also an
international base so we have Dutch
Danish Norwegian South Korean everybody
coming together and that 35 is going to
be the backbone of our air power for the
next 50 years and so we had a once in a
career maybe once in a lifetime
opportunity to reimagine what pilot
train was going to be like for flying
the F-35 so we actually had a lot of
those questions that started with what's
our ultimate goal to build a F-35
wingman that can survive and thrive into
the late 2030s so that changed what
threats were worrying about
um and we used a lot of technology so
one thing that was interesting is we as
you said have used simulators quite a
bit over the years these simulators now
are incredible they are 50 million
dollar pieces of art they are domes that
are two stories high just for one
simulator and they the cockpit's exactly
the same as the F-35 and then it's on
tank tracks and it rolls you into the
middle of this Dome as one General said
this is a monument to human engineering
so they're phenomenal but and they do
have their place but the problem is we
didn't have anything that was less
Fidelity so students would learn the way
they always did memorize textbooks
they'd have a little bit of time in
these simulators because they were so
expensive we can only have a few of them
and then they go fly the F-35 which is
fifty thousand dollars an hour so one
thing that we came up with was having a
spectrum of devices when a student is
learning how to start the jet they don't
need this Monument to human engineering
we gave them gaming laptops something
easy something quick to get out there we
Declassified it so that they could take
it home with them gave them hotass
Hands-On stick and throttle
we came up with other devices well
virtual reality devices that were a step
up and we were flying with 360 cameras
in the F-35 security aspect was was
difficult even though you know it
doesn't sound that difficult and then
they'd be able to to play back we'd do a
lot of flame out Landings in the F-35
they'd be able to see exactly what that
sight picture was as opposed to the old
way of doing it using a a uh a dry erase
pen on a uh uh a sheet showing you know
how to do it so they could actually see
the site picture of an experienced
instructor doing it and then we started
layering in some other things like
overlays of where the instructor was
looking how they were doing it and now I
I've been working with uh some the basic
pilot training they're testing some new
things using AI to be able to find some
key trends in what the student is doing
and it's not uh you know 100 solution
but it can find a few things that it
thinks the student might be screwing up
and then the instructor can look at that
and say oh yeah he is screwing that up
or can choose to discard it so Air Force
pilot training has really changed
drastically in just the last five years
or so all right what about training uh
from your perspective from Navy
perspective perhaps uh jtac was probably
where I was most recently involved in
and uh we had the same issue 20 million
dollar jtex sandwich actually went down
because there were some issues with the
contractor uh
alternatively there was a former seal
who I think his name's Brad Dunn who
developed a augmented reality and then
they were working with guys out of
Hollywood to create a four-dimensional
platform where you would actually feel
the platform would move as bombs dropped
near you danger closed you'd actually
have a heat wave just to increase the
intensity as you're in that process
um
and also becomes much more affordable
affordable and mobile we took some of
these platforms with us to Iraq where
now the jtacs can do practice their
training practice their calls in in you
know anywhere almost anywhere you have a
room you can now start training so so we
we talked Hazard earlier about your
encounter with um you know heavyweight
champion Tito Ortiz but but you also
trained at the United States Air Force
Academy
and that was a part of your
undergraduate curriculum you were you
studied boxing you took uh you were you
know took up the hobby but it became
part of this book and I assume a large
part of your mentality and there's two
there's one quote that you use but
there's one quote I was surprised you
didn't use so one quote you use is no
plan survives first contact with the
Enemy and the uh and the quote that I
was surprised you didn't use given your
boxing Heritage was the famous fighter
pilot Mike Tyson who said everyone has a
plan to he gets hit in the face what can
Ordinary People maybe that aren't as
Fearless heroic as you take away from
the the similarities between dog
fighting and physical fighting are there
commonalities are there ways are there
ways to keep your cool so that you don't
lose as much of your plan or you don't
you know lose your plan altogether when
you step into the room with a you know
with a formidable foe like Professor
Tyson
yeah I love that we're all uh yeah just
kidding he yeah there's a there's a lot
of commonality there and you know as I
talked to I the Air Force Academy is
located in Colorado Springs which is
also where the Olympic Training Center
is and I talk about a chance encounter I
had with a sports psychologist and we
really worked on staying in the present
moment visualization self-talk all those
uh you know kind of things that uh it
wasn't something that I I really focused
on as a boxer I really wanted to just
work on the technique but this emotional
side of things really made a big
difference in my boxing and so I applied
that to Air Force pilot training because
Air Force pilot training they're
stressing you to to the Limit they want
to see how you do when you fail and so
they will make you fail at some point or
another and so there are a lot of great
Pilots there we had commercial pilots
that were flying for American Airlines
before so they had a tremendous
advantage over people but at some point
in the curriculum you get to a point
where you have not seen that site
picture before and you will probably
fail and so what they wanted to do is
see what these people's character was
like and so that boxing sport psychology
background and training gave me a big
Advantage there I mean it gives me
advantage in any high stress situation
because there is a narrow band of
Excellence if you go too high talking
the book The Air Force has done a lot of
studies where if you are too stressed
out you really start losing as as we
talked 20 IQ points but it it changes
based on what you're trying to to do so
the biggest area where it decreases is
your spatial intelligence understanding
where different things are in space and
that's huge for flying so that's the
first thing to go high stress can help
you with some moderate uh to easy tasks
that
um that you know that you have down pat
so there is a benefit to stress but too
much and it really hurts you flying so
being able to uh being able to regulate
your emotions regulate your stress your
self-talk is really important and
that'll plan as I talked to as the Air
Force has moved to this Human
Performance aspect all Pilots as soon as
they show up they start this sports
psychology training that we've adapted
to uh to Flying Fighters and that
carries with them throughout their
career and I've seen a big difference in
the past there'd be students that would
be fine with they'd be great and they'd
make a mistake take and the the train
would leave the tracks and so now
they're a little bit better at being
able to uh to be able to regulate
themselves you don't want to be worrying
about a past problem you're dedicating
bandwidth to a past problem that you
can't affect now so you need to be
warned and using that bandwidth towards
uh towards solving the problem that's in
front of you I had an instructor and I
was puttering around and uh Cessna 152
actually it was a 150 I I can't even fit
into that anymore uh but I've had you
know a bunch of kids so I have an excuse
um and and you know he he used to say
when I make a good Landing he would
compliment himself because uh he felt it
was the instructor that ultimately had
to take credit and as you point out many
times in this book sadly many Pilots
have been lost including people that
you've known and loved and and you two
are you and uh and we you know our
hearts break for them but you say a
piece of all of us goes with them and
we're responsible at some level I wonder
uh you know how to not internalize that
and how to kind of move on I remember
reading a wonderful book by David Mendel
it's called digital Apollo and it's
about all the techniques technology that
both went into the Apollo Landing
missions and the technology that came
out of it for civilian news including
the autopilot and it turned out back
then in the 50s and 60s they could have
landed the Apollo Landers all of them
the eagle they could have landed
themselves but they built in the
capability that you know the lunar
Command Module pilot could actually take
over at the last minute if he needed to
and uh and they found that every single
pilot even when the footage would later
prove them wrong would say oh at the
last minute I saw a crater I saw a big
boulder I saw an alien no no didn't see
any aliens but I saw this out of the
corner of my eye I had to take over and
it's because they said in the Mandela
makes a point in the book that Landing
is kind of like the consummate ultimate
expression of the pilot in other words
that's that's the most piloting thing a
pilot can do so of course they want to
take over and do this thing and land it
and not let some stupid computer how do
you teach your students to like to to
view and autopilot these augmented
systems as not a threat to their
masculinity or femininity there's a lot
of female fighter pilots uh as you guys
both know well
um but how do you let them overcome and
see it as a partner and I'm gonna
obviously dovetail into Ai and augment
that stuff how did you like handle that
like to teach them that actually no it's
not a dominant immunization
I can't speak uh
diminishing your own capability as a
pilot it's nothing negative about you
but instead it's something that should
be welcome did you ever encounter that
Ariel
not uh I mean probably the best example
we were
forced to actually land manually on
behind the boat every every night to get
practice but there was a time where my
Skipper specifically said I want
everyone in the Squadron in the next
week to do a uh I believe it was a
a little black uh anyway there's a
automated approach and I'm blanking on
the name of it right now uh where the
plane takes over and flies you in uh
into the wires at night which as uh most
people could probably imagine Landing
behind the boat at night is is never
really fun you're you're descending into
a dark black abyss you only have a
couple lights behind the boat the boat's
moving away from you at 30 knots and
it's it's moving up and down
um so it's never a fun process and it's
definitely one of the most stressful uh
things that you do as a Navy fighter
pilot and that night you know I I
selected in autopilot plane is coming
down and I mean it was the nicest
approach have flown and it it was
humbling it's like yeah that this thing
can actually do it better now that
system's not always reliable so you
still need to rely you know develop the
skills as a pilot yourself but you know
you slowly start incorporating these
systems you start noticing that yes this
is it's it's value added now I can you
know after seven hour combat flight I'd
be a little bit less worried about
coming back to the boat because if I am
having you know we've talked about go
pills which I generally try to avoid but
would take if needed
now as you're coming back to the boat
you can go okay hey if I'm not on the
top of my game anymore I have this
backup option if this backup option is
working it's going to get me on I'm
going to have my mid-rats which is our
midnight meal uh probably one of the
most important meals on the boat
um and one of the main motivators to get
yourself uh onto the deck so so top gun
Maverick would never have happened if
that existed back in the Tomcat days
because the guy that Maverick leads onto
the boat at night in the weather he
could have just said you know Screw
Maverick I'm just gonna go myself ended
up a Top Gun the rest would not be
history uh Hazard anyway to you know
advise students or you know I'm asking
self-interested as well it's not
threatening you know it shouldn't be you
know diminishment as I say or tried to
say of of your ability skill set or
identity is there any any tips to kind
of help the psychological factors
yeah that is interesting question and by
the way in the F-35 the it's so precise
the guys landing on the carrier are
wearing out the skid pads because it
hits every time in the same spot
that's the same Landing system yeah like
I think it's magic carpet but uh yeah it
I think I think of myself as as kind of
a modern fighter pilot you are
organizing and utilizing all this
technology so I don't see a lot of
people
staking their masculinity on being able
to manually do Maneuvers it would be
interesting to go back and talk to some
of those Apollo Pilots because they
probably grew up in the the 30s the 40s
when it was fully manual biplanes you
know that they were learning how to fly
on
but now I think it's just so ingrained
in us when I was going through pilot
training you know I grew up with with
real basic video games Nintendo all
those things and we could process a lot
more information than my instructors and
my instructors would say your class you
know just just can understand this a lot
better than than I can and can retain
more information the same thing today so
we're getting kids that are in there
early 20s and they've grown up with an
iPad in their crib and so the F-35 is
essentially a flying sensor it has two
giant iPads in front of you you can talk
to it and it does things augmented
reality helmet so I don't think there's
that necessary barrier to uh to being
able to rely on technology every once in
a while I'll see a student that likes to
manually get the setup parameters done
for uh for bfm and you know if they can
do it I say more power to you but
usually they'll screw something up and
I'll say look you can you know have the
option of relying on the auto throttle
it's not a it's not a knock on you do
that so that you have more mental
bandwidth to be able to focus on
something that matters
do you ever find that
uh some of the Lost skill sets uh end up
being important so I'll bring it from
the the last three years I was working
as a jtac and we had these devices that
would kind of give you a pretty good
God's eye view of the battlefield
um but there'd be occasions where you
know I I set a Target that was right
below a giant red uh water tower and
they'll be down there trying to figure
out how to prosecute this and get the
the Pilot's eyes onto the target when it
could be as simple as looking up looking
at your environment going hey do you see
the giant water tower that's you know on
the coast here and the pilot would
immediately get there so sometimes I
found that the technology can be
detrimental and that you do get if you
get too soaked into it you start losing
situational awareness of the of the
overall picture but that absolutely you
just want to you you want to start at
the big picture and work your way down
so if your head's down working through
Sub Sub menu because you're focused on
that and that's kind of the the process
that I talk about in the book work at
the big picture get a rough
approximation of what the solution is
and then you can always refine that
later on I think that that is a problem
especially new students that can't
necessarily prioritize as well or absorb
as much data as well is that they get
they glom off on the radar F-16 was it
was a really big problem because it
didn't have any Sensor Fusion your brain
was a Sensor Fusion so as a Rat's Nest
of Technology from the 80s 90s 2000s and
so unfortunately we had six times the
the cfit controlled flight into terrain
where Pilots either passing out or uh is
flying low and is misprioritizing and
running into a mountain because they're
working the radar or the uh you know
radar warning receiver so as a pilot I
think always work with the big picture
and and then go down from there because
you can get yourself into some big big
problems if you do it the other way
around
so a lot of the counter-intuitive wisdom
in this book comes from the uh as I said
counterintuitive realization that many
things in life are non-linear that we
expect you know kind of doubling the
output when you double the input but
many of these things are exponential and
worse and one of the things that you
don't mention in the book but but it
kind of instantly came to my mind was
this also this uh this anecdote from
Aviation which is why is the 787 which
cost less and and um you know took maybe
shorter to develop uh why is that
proving better for the airlines than the
A380 these giant you know 500 passenger
behemoths and and the reason that I've
heard comes down to a very
counter-intuitive thing which is that uh
which is that the A380 has so many
people on it uh that it's very difficult
to Envision that one of those 570 people
at Max load is not going to have a heart
attack or some other kind of emergency
uh versus you know maybe 250 on a
Dreamliner it's last May be a third
lesser or what have you on different
configurations it's less likely to have
an emergency now when you land because
there's an emergency you're limited
because of the time you have to rest the
brakes if I'm not mistaken before you
can attempt you know a takeoff again so
the A380 will have to be on the ground
longer because it's heavier and these
kind of the dwell time and the brake
Heating and stuff causes the cube of the
mass of the plane or something like that
so trying to optimize it to carry more
passengers is actually detrimental and
so airlines are finding they can't get
as many sorting they can't fly as many
people net net because of these
non-linear factors and yet the human
mind is very poorly adapted to this
we're used to seeing yeah if we struggle
twice as hard we'll if we run twice as
fast we'll you know get away from that
that tiger or whatever we don't see many
non-linear things how do you enure
people or get them a custom Hazard to
thinking non-linearly is it a matter of
heuristics of you know rules of thumb
what kind of advice do you have for
people dealing in the corporate world
perhaps they're going to read love and
digest this Wonder full book to
recognize when you're dealing with a
power loss situation and then apply the
art of clear thinking yeah I think the
biggest way is to graph the data it's a
simple tool that's been around for
thousands hundreds if not thousands of
years so being able to graph the data
and it just pops out to you so that's
what we do for most of the different uh
relationships that we have when we're
flying so our relationship our Energy
Management going back to John Boyd is
graphed
um and we can just overlay that with
enemy Fighters and we can see where our
Jets have an advantage versus another
jet uh same thing with uh when we're
trying to geolocate Sam threats what
we're doing is we're doing a lot of
different tactics we're all sensor nodes
and being able to neck it down behaves
uh quite uh behaves non-linearly so
being able to just graph the data I
think is the single biggest thing and
being aware of how extreme non-linear
events can be so I I you know
everybody's heard of the the grain of
rice on the the chess board or the
doubling Penny it just you know gets to
a tremendous amount very quickly so I
think even people that understand those
linear relationships it's good to
continually refresh and understand that
because I think we are relying more and
more on technology software or something
that is very non-linear these Jets uh
we we will get a new software load and
in one case overnight everything got 25
better so it unlocked the gun uh we
could pull more G's
um so software is something where you
know two average people does not equal
one good person so you can find somebody
that is a hundred times 500 times better
than uh than the average person and it
can have a tremendous uh effect on how
capable you can be on the battlefield so
I think these relationships play out
throughout every aspect of of Our Lives
not just in the cockpit
did you know
no so um we have a bunch of questions I
just want to take a little pause to
refresh and uh let everybody know we're
talking with Hazard Lee who not only as
the author of this wonderful book The
Art of clear thinking also has a podcast
uh which I am devouring uh phenomenal
YouTube channel and uh most delightfully
so that you can like live that Instagram
lifestyle uh his Instagram channel is
off the hook I hope you guys will follow
him there and also on LinkedIn where he
dishes out daily doses of business
Acumen and wisdom
um also one of the well I should point
out you're you're the first guest that's
that's yeah I've had on astronauts I
actually had on Jessica my ear who may
be the first woman to walk on the moon's
surface she's a PhD graduate of UCSD it
turns out I had her on when she was on
the ISS flying overhead you know a
little bit faster than you guys can fly
but only for now uh and that was uh that
was about three years ago now but she
didn't read she doesn't have a book but
she didn't read from the audiobook in
the cockpit or in the ISS so you were to
be commended for that uh it's so uh it's
it's really fun when you're listening to
audiobook and you've been hearing Hazard
and it's kind of calm draw then you hear
him on over the intercom system uh with
the with the book in hand and he's got
some pictures of himself on his
Instagram feed doing just that uh so
thank you for that Hazard
um so when you're uh conveying that in
the book it really feels like you're in
the cockpit how did you I mean this is a
first time book uh talk about your your
writing process are there commonalities
we have a lot of authors that listen to
this podcast
um talk about are there commonalities
are there ways you know tools that you
use besides begging the forbearance of
your lovely wife I assume uh and and and
your kids who you acknowledge in the
book
um what are how did you convey how did
you work to convey that and do it so so
spectacularly well in your first ever
you know kind of your first sortie out
of the box yeah it was it was incredibly
challenging so this is ultimately is the
end of a six-year Journey so the reason
I started the Instagram and and all of
that is because
so I had gotten back in 2017 from
Afghanistan
um and so I started to it was a really
busy time we we were really active out
there and so I was writing down some of
the stories and decompressing that way
while I was waiting for F-35 training so
I was like you know be interesting to uh
to write a book and it turns out if you
don't have an audience uh you know and
you're not like a celebrity or something
you you really have no chance of writing
a book and so I was like well maybe I
can do a podcast
um and that coincided with another thing
Luke Air Force Base was looking for a
speaker on Memorial Day to talk about uh
loss and some things like that and
there's a teacher in the crowd and she
was like my students have to hear this
so I started speaking in classrooms and
so those two things coincided and I
started a podcast because it was a
digital way to get things out and that
evolved into the the YouTube and the
Instagram to be able to promote that and
I was able to get a book deal
and it was it was exciting the book deal
part was exciting it was like getting
drafted by the NFL we got into a little
bit of a bidding war and uh that was the
last time I heard from anybody for a
year so I I spent over a year uh I spent
actually over 500 days in a row writing
the book so every morning I'd write from
this office about four hours every
morning and it was just Brute Force
um to start off I would I would look
through some authors I really like Atul
gwanda is a really good one checklist
Manifesto if you haven't read that it's
a fantastic one so I would I would look
at how he interwoves stories and just
break down every sentence every
paragraph uh every chapter same thing
with Malcolm Gladwell and uh after that
I was Off to the Races I'm a slow writer
I would write about 500 Words a day
sometimes it'll be a thousand two
thousand and then I would come back the
next day and say oh this is terrible
um and have to delete it but they most
authors say that the key to writing a
book is to just get a crappy first draft
out there and that's what I did
what they don't tell you is now you have
a crappy first draft and you still have
a lot of work ahead of you so I went
through nine revisions uh to to Really
Hammer this book and and to condense it
and make it uh make it as precise as I
could so it was a it was an amazing
journey uh very painful but in a good
way where you know you're proud of of
something you've done yeah well that
really leads to growth and again uh I
think they say about writing a book that
it's uh years of of boredom punctuated
by moments of sheer Terror or that's
only when your kids come in the room uh
the C and A stands for choose I wonder
if we could highlight maybe we'll bring
this in if YouTube doesn't give us a
copyright strike you know one of the
best uh ever songs about uh about
decision making is of course Russia's
living in the Limelight where it said
that even when you choose not to decide
you still have made a choice I don't
know what the other lyrics are I won't
sing it because I have gotten copyright
strikes before
um I remember a saying for my stepfather
who's an Air Force um grad as I said and
also I'm in Vietnam he used to say you
know uh you could be right and you can
be dead uh so meaning that you could the
air traffic controller can be telling
you to do something and you feel like
well he or she is an authority I'm gonna
have to do it you know she's but I'm
actually right and and you know and and
take the take the initiative uh but
maybe sometimes they're right and and
you can make the right choice sometimes
it'll leave you dead even though you did
it and that night you know my stepfather
Ray would say you know the controller is
going to go home he's going to cry to
his wife and it's had a bad day and next
day he'll be back at work and he'll be
dead so how do you you know handle those
situations how do you know when you
shouldn't choose Sometimes the best
option is not to choose and I'm sure you
guys have both heard the saying you know
like the first thing you do when there's
an emergency is they used to say to the
pilots in World War II you know wind
your watch uh you know mainly take a
pause take a bit how do you know when to
to make a choice and sometimes when not
to make a choice how do you know when to
execute the c or not to see if you will
yeah well in the F-16 actually there is
still a wind-up clock in there so I I
talked about how instructors would say
you know wind that clock another saying
is uh you can always make something
worse so uh so you don't want to just
start jumping to action so yeah being
able to I think assess leads to to
figuring out uh what choices of action
uh courses of action that you are
choosing so it's when you're looking at
the assessment it's it it follows a
diminishing uh return law so you can
stick around for in the case of flying
two minutes five minutes trying to
figure out the decision
but at some point you're the point where
you're spending more time trying to
assess that decision you should probably
make some sort of decision and hopefully
it resets that diminishing return law
and you start Gathering more information
and then you can make another decision
there so I think the key is Discerning
between is this something irreversible
or is it something that you can update
later on if it's irreversible you want
to spend more time making that
assessment if it's something that you
can reverse it probably makes sense to
gather the information make a decision
reset that diminishing return law and
then to to go from there and keep
iterating as you're moving forward like
patins quota a good plan executed
violently today is better than a perfect
plan executed tomorrow so sometimes you
know and same in aviation like flew a
lot of single engine aircraft if
something goes wrong with the engine
turn get towards a field now start
assessing your problem set
um but yeah you know once again you know
F-18 same thing like we had two engines
there was nothing thing almost no
emergency they're required in immediate
action like make sure you're gonna shut
the right engine down make sure you're
gonna right you were saying once you
know like a lot of Pilots pulled the
wrong engine and they do the shutdown
right is that that doesn't happen to
Hazard because he's flying single engine
if you shut down the engine yeah but you
can always lose that engine so you know
you're always five minutes away from
having to to outrun the Taliban
um talk about the phenomenon of tunnel
vision when you have this kind of get
their itis I always say to my wife you
know the most dangerous things I'll ever
say when I'm puttering around a little
sustenance I'll be home exactly at 5 PM
you know because when you do that you're
you're committing you've got you know
the sunk cost file so you've got to make
it I'm going to let her down you know
she's gonna the the dinner's gonna get
cold and you know I don't miss many
meals how do you guys deal with that
tunnel vision that mono maniacal Focus
what are some tools tricks for Mortals
to deal with uh tunnel vision and um and
getting breaking out of that again the
the hard part is maybe you know one of
these guests that I hope to have on one
day Derek sivers uh he used to say
things like you know if knowledge where
all that was required we'd all be
billionaires with six-pack abs so it's
not just knowledge how do you know when
you're in the tunnel how do you know how
to punch out of that tunnel any any
ideas guys
it's yeah I can go so you know you don't
rise to the level of your expectation
you fall to your level of preparation so
I think a lot of it comes down to
training yourself and and inoculating
yourself to that stress both being
prepared for that moment and
understanding all the aspects of it but
also from a kind of a meta skill of
understanding how to withstand that that
pressure so I think working out is
important even if you're uh if even if
you're a scientist and you're in the
you're not using your muscles it it's a
stress there that that carries over and
your ability to be able to manage that
stress so I think that's one aspect is
being prepared and what we do when we're
flying uh training missions is to make
it far more complex and a lot more
difficult than it is in the battlefield
we try to push ourselves because there's
really no way to to replicate how
stressful it is in combat so you can
push yourself as much as possible there
so that when you get to combat it's a
little bit less difficult than uh than
if you uh if you didn't do that secondly
some some minor tips one is a lot of
students have these issues when they're
refueling for the first time so we'll
have Airborne gas stations essentially
and it's a fully manual maneuver you're
there's a essentially an airliner full
of fuel hundreds of thousands of pounds
and you pull it behind it and it's
really easy to crash into it and cause a
giant Fireball so a lot of students are
really nervous the tip that we give them
is wiggle your fingers wiggle your toes
because you start really clinching
everything clenching your jaw and uh and
you know you can reverse that stress by
wiggling your fingers wiggling your toes
taking deep breaths
we use uh it really depends how much
oxygen demand you need but a easy
heuristic is is box breathing five
seconds in hold five seconds five
seconds out hold five seconds but the
big thing is just not hyperventilating
so trying to slow down your breathing as
much as possible and then lastly for me
it's literally expanding that tunnel
vision so looking out of the corner your
eyes it's called tunnel vision you know
not just because cognitively you're
focused on a single thing but you you
actually your vision shrinks down so I
find when I look out of the corner
corners of my eyes and open that Vision
up I start to detach and breathe and
that's a really important thing when
you're shown up at fire close air
support fire fights that the troops on
the ground are under a lot more stress
than you are so when we show up we have
to be that calming Force detached and be
able to think through it because they're
dodging bullets down there and it's our
job to be able to to make good decisions
and to be that calming Force that's
detached from what's going on in the
ground
yeah I'll add the only thing I'll add is
also command climate so in your wife's
example would be you know making sure
that she understands the danger if she
gives you a hard deadline
um and you see that in commands as well
like there are times where a skipper or
someone is is a bit more totalitarian
and authoritarian wants you to do what
they want you to do and that can drive
you to make those tunnel uh tunnel like
decision making so making sure that
everyone's on board that you know in the
end you're the aircraft commander and
they they understand it will respect the
choice that you end up making so you
know you don't make it to dinner
hopefully you don't hear hear about it
for the next week that's right and if
that's the worst thing that happens on a
flight that's uh that's not nothing to
be too ashamed about
um so Hazard there's undoubtedly uh
millions of people watching this uh you
know and either one of our different
platforms um they're thinking look you
guys are commanders of you know
multi-million dollar aircraft I think
what I the 35 35's uh uh close to 100
million dollars a unit is that right
yeah so correct what can he possibly
teach me you know I'm running you know a
sticker uh business where I do you know
uh wallpaper and paint supplies so so
has talked to people out there what what
are the commonalities what are the
lessons the teachings the learnings
that's just an ordinary person not a
superhero not you know one of my uh one
of my questions for my audience which
the last now is you know how how do you
feel that they used your image for Buzz
Lightyear and your persona but they
don't give you royalties okay so you're
you're like this magical superhero you
guys
um but it's an ordinary you know man or
woman or a tall you know car dealer in
Tulsa Oklahoma what are they going to
take away from this book yeah so I try
to distill it down in its decision
making if you boil down my job as a fire
pilot it's to make decisions and I think
it's more important than ever now
the average person Burns 90 watts of
electricity and yet the average American
is burning 12 000 watts and that powers
the technology that's leveraging the
decisions that we're making so I think
decision making is one of the most
important skills and yet it's not taught
I think from a leadership perspective
that
we are moving from era of management
which came out of the Industrial
Revolution managing hundreds if not
thousands of people in a factory to now
I think it was Bloomberg uh was saying
Bloomberg Finance was saying they expect
a billion dollar company to be run by
three people in the next 10 years
so that is due to leveraging AI they
expect to be an AI company leveraging
technology so three people versus in the
1800s it probably took uh took a hundred
thousand people to be able to run a uh
what would have been a billion dollar
company so
technology is leveraging the decisions
we're making it happens when I'm flying
my jet I can travel 100 times faster
than I could by foot I can carry 100
times more I'm literally thousands of
times more capable than I could be on my
own same thing with your phone you can
do uh it can do the job of dozens of
people from just a few years ago car you
can go 10 times faster modern combine
harvester you can Harvest crops hundreds
of times faster than you can by hand so
it really comes down to being able to
make good precise decisions and and
that's something that applies to
everybody yeah absolutely
um so in a few minutes I'm gonna go
teach myself and I'm going to apply the
Lessons Learned hopefully my students
will think clearly so we're going to
reach the moment we're going to ask some
rapid fire questions
um from the audience so I hope you'll uh
indulge us a little bit Hazard with some
some quick answers and and so forth um
okay so this comes from uh oh by the way
thanks for pointing out the billion
dollar company that's good to know that
Stewart and I my super producer we can
do the job of three people with just two
people and become a billion dollar
podcast so Stewart asked the following
question uh are these myths I'm going to
go through a couple different things as
a fighter pilot are you living
dangerously do do you ride a motorcycle
do you need to have perfect vision and
uh is Chuck Yeager kind of your avatar
hero so first of all do you have to are
you a dangerous person dangerous living
person
uh not not anymore I I think uh growing
up I really wanted to to do something
risky but now I see it as more of a risk
versus reward system so most of the time
not but I'm I'm not afraid to get my
hands dirty ride a motorcycle motorcycle
no it's not not worth it to me it
doesn't cross that risk versus reward
threshold do you have to have 20 20
Vision to be a stealth fighter putt
great question no you don't so that's a
big myth that that was true back in the
day I fly with people that have contacts
uh glasses and have done LASIK
um
uh Chuck Yeager I I used to joke about
this you know when you get on the
Southwest Airlines flight you know
you're flying around the pile again you
know we're gonna cruise up Vector 74 up
to the coast
Oakland will start our decent and I'm
like you're flying this thing you push a
button you know 30 seconds after and no
I have a lot of Pilots that listen to
this podcast love you guys
um is it is he your avatar is Chuck
Yeager do you have who's your hero who
are your some of your pilot Heroes I
would say John Boyd uh Chuck Yeager
definitely for for what he did and being
able to to get in that cockpit of the
the X1 but I would say John Boyd that'd
be uh the one that I wouldn't would want
to go back and see
um
so yeah that's that's probably the one
uh what about you all right probably uh
Robin olds and then a bunch of the
Apollo Astronauts who were you know
started their life off as as fighter
pilots that's true okay uh Hazard what
enemy aircraft do you still fear the
most
still fear uh Fitch and fighter aircraft
so
uh there are a couple ones out there uh
257 j-20 so those those are the more
advanced aircraft out there but Mass
also the matters people understand that
how many aircraft do you have
the thousandth F-35 is rolling off the
line right now versus these other
countries only have a few amount of them
so Mass matters
uh would you fly with a completely
artificial intelligent pilot wingman or
wing woman or Wing I I whatever Wing It
Wing thing would you would you feel
comfortable with that right off your
wing
depends how good it is so yes I I would
if it if it could prove itself so I'm
not I don't have a ideological issue
with that I think we have a long long
ways to go to be able to replace the
fighter pod I think we'll be here for a
long time but I do think we'll have some
AI wingmen that can help us out and
that's going to be a good thing
um we you talk a lot in the book about
the F-117 Nighthawk which was only one
or two or one I think malfunction and
one was shot down uh by a combination
and I'll leave it I hate when you go on
a podcast as an author the host asked
you well just explain all your greatest
stories in the book and I'll give my
audience a free audiobook version of it
no no we're not going to do that but
you'll have to it was really gripping I
I could not stop listening to that
portion of the podcast F-117 I've heard
is being resurrected even uh there's one
out here in Palm Springs if you ever
want to come visit to us and SoCal we'll
take you out there uh there's perfect
restoration of it in a hardened bunker
but anyway what uh what what is you know
the secret to its success I mean it was
designed in the 70s you talk about that
the B2 is allegedly maybe more stealthy
but it's also more massive and bigger uh
but the 117 they seem to have gotten it
right the first time it's even more
stealthy than the F-35 right so uh why'd
they retire it why not just keep it
around
yeah it was just old old technology so
it they couldn't model curved services
so if you look at it it's very angular
so it is his old technology the stealth
coding took a lot of Maintenance there
wasn't great avionics in it the weapons
Loadout wasn't great it uh didn't have
an air-to-air capability or a a very
good one so there are a lot of issues
with it
um so it wasn't maneuverable
um so yeah a lot of issues with it
there's really you know no no tactical
use to to keep them uh as of now even
and I I think I told my one of my sons
once that the uh
that the F-14 which is his favorite
plane uh he has two two Desires in life
he wants to be an F-14 pilot and a rabbi
I said I think that's gonna be tough
because the only country that still
flies them is the is the Iranian uh
Republican guard
um I want to ask both of you guys what
is in your dream Hangar if I could lay
upon you that billion dollars when you
start uh you turn the professionals
Playbook into just a money making
Revenue Source Hazard you buy your dream
hanger what's in it and then I'm gonna
ask Ariel the same question
so F-16 is still my favorite aircraft so
I I recently had a chance to fly with
the first civilian F-16 so they exist
out there so I am definitely going to
have an F-16 in there there's a new
company called black shape that are
making carbon fiber tandem uh aircraft
uh they're kind of like the Ferraris of
the sky so I'm gonna have one of those
in there gotta have a P51 or some sort
of warbird
um you're getting me excited so I mean
I'm gonna have to stop there but I'd
have a lot of planes the wife would not
be happy all right all right what about
you
having gotten one flight in F16 I can uh
you know definitely uh back him up on
that
um amazing aircraft uh P51 for sure
extra 300 was a lot of fun to fly
um
I'd probably also put some sort of golf
stream so I could fly my family to ski
trips but
uh Hazard as you know on Modern
podcasting it's important to talk about
AI we talked a little bit about that
um and you also I want to refer folks to
my friend James all toucher's podcast
with you which is just uh you know James
sets the standard for many of us out
there he talked a little bit more about
that there but the other thing the other
two mandatory topics AI chat GPT and
then there's also Bitcoin which you know
we're not going to talk about Bitcoin uh
but then the third topic we have to talk
about alien encounters uh I am not at
Liberty to talk about the alien
autopsies that I've been a part of or
might not have been a part of
um what do you make of the recent NASA
funded UAP which uh which is uh led by
David spurgle president Simons
Foundation is the benefactor behind most
of my research uh so I have to be
kidding I love David and he's he's
completely intellectually honest uh
here's my advisor back and he was
Ariel's advisor at Princeton Universe by
the way Ariel's call sign is pie pie
and he would have to read out all you
know all digits I never read out the
digits because the middle four decimals
are my uh pin number at the ATM Hazard
uh any any encounters maybe not you know
extraterrestrial in origin but anything
that you could not explain or understand
during your historic career
so I'm not gonna say I ever ran into
aliens but there are a lot of things
that you you see in the air that you
don't have a full understanding of so
you'll see things on the radar you'll
see your targeting pod out and see dots
out there so you do see a lot of things
like that I'm not going to say that
they're aliens because really as fighter
pilots you're so focused on on the
mission at hand I think the same thing
happens when you're driving if you're on
a long road trip you see a lot of things
out there that you're like I don't know
what that is it's kind of a glint off
the the mountain face or something like
that
um and you don't have the time to to go
deviate and and go check that out so I
have seen a lot of things that uh I
don't fully understand but uh
I'm not prepared to say that they're any
sort of uh aliens they might might have
been just uh some sort of uh
you know balloons flying around things
like that in the middle of a mission
when you're too busy uh focus on that to
really give full attention to this
what about you and your your buddy Ryan
Graves uh the balloons is actually
probably my closest was I picked up some
weird radar returns locked them up
intercepted turned out to be balloons
and then another time right after
launching a carrier picked up a
radar hit queued my 9x it got uh tone
ended up doing a left to left with the
Iranian drone but uh no sadly uh uh Ryan
Ryan and I were uh Squadron mates uh
we're still good friends I was at his
wedding um
I unfortunately never saw the stuff that
he he got to see so um even though one
of the um battleships out there was the
Princeton right
um okay we're almost at the end Hazard I
thank you for your patience and your
Indulgence
um when you're flying by wire one of the
most famous examples again we're not
going to get into it because it's such a
cool and amazingly applicable to any
domain Aviation or not the story of the
Airbus crash that leads off the book Air
France I believe it was back in 09 and
10.
um Fly by wire is that something that's
really removing the stick and Rudder the
Chuck Yeager is that diminishing the
Pilot's aptitude at all
not at all so fly by wire is something
we've been doing since the 1970s with
the F-16 and it is pretty eye-watering
now so in the F-35
we're running a continuous model of the
aircraft line and when I put in an input
it's not necessarily the flight controls
that are making uh the traditional
flight controls that are making that
happen the jet will figure out the best
way to do that and the best example I
can use is in that first Top Gun when
when Mavericks in that flat spin out to
see out of control we do that routinely
like we we will do that on purpose and
have uh precise ability to to increase
the spin rate or less so uh you know you
can never do that without a flight
control system so it really makes you a
better pilot now the extension of that
of AI and stuff like that there's
there's a lot of issues but in terms of
just a pure flight control system it's
very beneficial and makes us a lot more
agile because these jets would go out of
control they're fundamentally uh they're
unstable system so you need those inputs
from the computer to keep it flying okay
a few more questions here do you have a
comment around
um I have a
sort of controversial topic for the uh
A10 versus F-35 and I was kind of
curious as to your perspective I know
the air force uh has been trying to get
rid of the A10 for a while as someone
who did a tour with the jtac found the
A10 to be an amazing aircraft I'm
curious to as to what your thoughts are
on replacing A10 Fleet with the F-35
yeah that's a good one definitely
controversial
um it really depends on what we're doing
so if we are pivoting towards great
power competition like the national
defense strategy is saying then I think
we have to be prepared for a higher end
battery and you can see it playing out
in Ukraine any aircraft flying low is
getting shot down and so I uh had a
chance to do a interview of an A-10 uh
pilot at Nellis Air Force Base their
test uh test Squadron there and they're
saying they're not planning on shooting
the gun ever in these conflicts so now
they tend to get rid of the gun the
primary thing because it's going to have
to fly at high altitude because those
Man portable air defense systems are
going to be shooting shooting them down
even though there's a lot of armor
there's a lot of those man pads out
there so if we are pivoting towards this
great power competition uh with with
higher end threats then it probably
makes sense to uh to either uh you know
kind of mothball the A10 or to downsize
it depending on how the finances look
but it's it's probably not going to be
that survivable in these conflicts last
question for both of you guys and then
I've studied this in great detail can
Ukraine win this conflict without air
superiority can they do it with drones
um Arielle I know you've thought about
this a little bit
um so is a drone you know kind of a DGI
Wars this is this a new new theater
class weapon or how can they win a war
with I mean no more has been one without
air Superior art at least in my silly
understanding military history uh so
correct me if I'm wrong so is air
superiority necessary if not sufficient
my fear with Ukraine more is that it's
become a war of attrition and uh without
being able to go after the supply lines
from other side you're just gonna
continually grind down your forces
um
in terms of air superiority uh I think
Ukraine can probably get its territory
back without it I haven't given this too
much thought
um
where air superiority would come into a
nice would be a benefit would be that
ability to go into enemy territory to
take out their nodes to take out their
fuel supply ammunition supply all the
their Logistics chain that gets their
troops into the battlefield to begin
with
um and obviously there are limitations
on on the scale of that war great and uh
Hazard any thoughts from you on air
superiority's necessity yes so that uh
as long as they can prevent Russia from
having their security I think they can
win so that's my specialty is the
suppression of enemy air defense so in
Top Gun 2 the the missiles along the
canyon walls taking those sand bites out
and so Russia has failed to do that with
Ukraine and so Ukraine has prevented uh
Russia from having air superiority so as
long as we can keep those Sam sites by
Ukraine uh operating and having missiles
then I think there's a very good chance
of uh of Ukraine being able to to hold
off
yeah
well uh Hazard uh I want to ask you if
there are anything other topics that
you'd like to talk about before we close
out and I start to apply these lessons
not the lethal lessons of of course but
to my class
um anything else that you want to
mention besides the podcast
professionals Playbook your LinkedIn
Instagram YouTube channel which is an
inspiration
um and this wonderful book it was really
a gift to me as a not just as a pilot
you know aspiring to to sometimes have a
have a greaser Landing but also to be a
better leader manager and think more
clearly can you uh let me know any other
things you'd like to bring up
no that was it this has been great I
really appreciate you having me on I'm
really happy that you enjoyed the book
and especially the audiobook the
audiobook uh I just bought your book I I
need to get the audio one did you uh did
you record it yourself not my first book
my second book I did some of the
audiobook but the end of my third book
it's one third of the 23 hours of
conversation of Galileo is me so yes it
is okay it's a treat to to hear your
actual voice and uh I really appreciate
the Artistry of it and not surprising
for a book with art and its title
hazardly uh your inspiration your hero
people compare you a favorably to Buzz
Aldrin Buzz Lightyear
um and uh you're you're a phenomenal
writer this is this is just such a treat
thank you for your service both of you
gentlemen and uh and thank you for all
for joining us on the into the
impossible podcast remember you can
always ask me questions and ask Hazard
questions about the book he loves to
interact on Instagram especially
LinkedIn as well and uh please uh please
do keep in touch Hazard and I hope you
have many many books courses as I said
supplements you know just just give me a
little cut and and especially motion
sickness bags like like our friend
Russell Monroe we need some hazardly
branded uh motion sickness in all
honesty uh major majorly thank you so
much for joining us on the impossible
podcast
thank you Brian this has been great
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic
[Music]